Have you ever wondered what the eccentric,
dangerous Dr. Bright wants more than anything
in the world?
Foundation researchers used SCP-978, The Desire
Camera, to snap a photo of Dr. Bright while
he was having a heated argument with Dr. Clef.
Dr. Clef was not caught on camera, and only
Dr. Bright was captured in the photograph.
This was the result:
"Entire scene has changed.
Appears to be outside, sky in background,
grass in foreground.
Subject of picture is simple tombstone bearing
the engraving "Jack Bright, Resting at Last.""
A surprisingly somber wish from a figure that
has brought so much chaos to those around
him.
Maybe one day, he will finally find his peace.